Peggy's 16 so are you gonna invite me in  this dildo who's been dating my mom and  now he's moving in with us  it'll be better than you think Chloe  you'll see what a stable home can be  like hey we can figure all of that out  there is no home not if he's there Chloe  I can't go home anymore  is this junkyard all I've got left I've  got a little job for you I'm taking you  to Blackwell find the money and I'll  meet you to pick it up if I do this then  we're good no we got to go  talk to me Chloe I know I [ __ ] up I  know you and I know what you're capable  of it  everything's been magical since we  started hanging out  don't you just feel like everything's  possible how do you know which way is up  when your whole life has been turned  upside down who are you [ __ ]  you